and she turns around and says are you a
supporter of our kelly
turned around
where did that come from she would have
to break she would have to break it down
for me the song and i'm like oh ra no
[Music]
so the question was obviously like i
said i've already asked something very
similar to this one thing but so as i
was saying about how
if i went to a therapist and they showed
a mirror to myself yeah
what would i be concerned about seeing
what do i think in terms of like how
relationships of my life have ended
what do you think root causes for your
behaviors in those relationships like
what traits do you think you have
typically in relationships with
necessity with people or friends or
whatever
that um so when i said for example for
context when i was like
i have an attitude of if someone says to
me
oh
i love you or i've given you this and i
do this for you i do that for you my
immediate reaction would be like that's
your business no one told you to do that
i never asked you to do anything for me
and like a very defensive thing and i
can trace back
times all potential reasons as to why
i'm like that
is there anything that you think like
um
relationship wise where you'll be like
this is an actual trait i have
definitely and it's not a positive one
um and i think it's because of this um i
know a definite trait that i do have but
in terms of the the root i'm not too
sure but maybe i can discover it as i'm
speaking all right cool so a definite
trait i have is what you said prior to
us hitting record is
not wanting to hurt other people's
feelings so i
i would always put my
emotions
over there or know their feelings over
my emotions
i put their feelings over my emotions
and regardless of how i feel about a
certain situation if i know it can
if i know by me not saying what i want
to say or me
not really
being my 100 self in this current
situation i speak in my current mind or
specific mind
and that appeases her or makes her feel
better then i would i would opt for that
yeah than actually say in my mind
potentially hurting his or her feelings
whichever like situation i'm i'm in or
whatever i'm talking about rather and it
would
it would make me feel as if okay yes i
have
dealt with the situation but i've come
out the lesser i always feel as if i'm
the victim of a situation
oh okay in a sense of not necessarily a
victim but like i feel like
i don't necessarily speak my one hundred
percent truth because
i just don't want to
you're willing to hold the back i'm
willing to hold the bags yeah i'll bring
to hold it then rip the band-aid off
yeah yeah yeah you know and that's
that's been a trait of mine
for years
years and the thing is i don't know
where it stemmed from but i can remember
my
i can remember the earliest relationship
it started but i don't know why it
started
you know actually that's
now that i'm actually talking about yeah
yeah it's juicy it's it's it's coming to
you yeah yeah i think obviously you know
who it is the um the reason why i feel
like
this was the case
is because i actually don't know how
deep i can go into this
because i don't want it to
obviously only a certain amount of
people know
who
i speak about iu and you and stuff but
i'm not trying to
put it paint anyone in a bad light
so obviously you know what i went
through when i when i went with that
went through that breakup
a few years i said a few years ago this
was years ago years ago it was years ago
but you saw the kind of person i became
yeah yeah um in terms of like
immediately after like it wasn't a great
sight to see like it just it was messy
and
that stemmed from because we weren't we
were never on the right path
from the jump
um so let me break it down like i i was
seeing this girl
uh well i started to see this girl
rather
and ever when i say everything was
like the banter the attraction
everything was like bang bang it was
everything was measured and then
at that time to my knowledge
i hadn't felt or spoken to a nut to
another female the way i was speaking to
this female yeah yeah and
the it was like me speaking to you do
you know what i mean and that's how i
felt yeah yeah i felt like raw i can see
comfort that's comfort and that's that's
something i didn't know i was looking
for yeah do you know what i mean yeah
and i'd never felt that um with the
opposite sex prior yeah and it was a
great place to be i remember it was
literally i remem i was at your yard
um this is what we were going out in
north obviously back a day and i'm
saying that you're you're you're there
your mom's not brother and i remember
being on the phone with her for hours
bro um hours before when we got back
either when we got back
before i think i think could have been
even before maybe i landed that day
hours bro i'm like yo we speak yeah yeah
we speak so the first few months or
whatever were were fantastic you know
but it
it got to a point where
we kind of hit a rocky path because
it was one of those ones where i didn't
know what the streets was back then but
i knew
i didn't want i want to have my cake and
eat it basically
and i think i said to her
she said something along the lines of
um oh she was talking to someone and
someone asked her out or something along
those lines she said oh i'm seeing
someone but this is what she was saying
to me and i wrote this was video i
remember this was on whatsapp and i
remember where i was i was at deloitte
and i replied to her saying
something along the lines of oh you
shouldn't have said you're seeing
someone
um
maybe like i think i said something
along the lines of
we're friends or but we're more than
friends something like that but i said
to her you shouldn't have said well not
seeing someone and it kind of went
downhill yeah but she kind of got she
kind of got the gist of what i was
trying to say without me saying it and
in my mind i didn't think what i was
saying at the time was a bad thing yeah
yeah in my mind
because i was so
fixated on the fact that
my my headspace where i'm at right now
with you is great i'm also not in a
place where i've put myself forward to
say i'm trying to be in a relationship
with you but it was one of those ones
where
females wouldn't know before they know
females will always know before the guy
right and she knew way before me yeah
and i knew i knew a little too late yeah
it was one of those ones
that's when the imbalance started to
take place because when i said what i
said
she then took that as oh maybe i should
have put all my eggs in one basket and i
should run straight a little bit run
street a little bit and just not
necessarily run street but just not give
him what i was going to give him in
terms of like the affection all that
stuff all that energy all the eggs
basically and i didn't realize that
until it was too late because i was
thinking
i never thought something was anything
was wrong i said what i said and i
thought it was the right thing to say
because i was speaking my truth and i
think that was the beginning of the
downfall yeah in that situation because
a girl will cut you off immediately yeah
bro and it's not like she cut off yeah
but they'll make a decision like
if they're on a a specific path yeah
upwards yeah all it takes is like a
slight hiccup and they're like cool i'm
not gonna block your number but just now
we can never go that high it can never
be that high again five years down the
line and it could never be like what do
you mean yeah like you said this to me
three would you say you said we were
boys yeah four years ago yeah so we're
boys aren't we yeah yeah yeah so it's
it's slowly started to take a spiral did
obviously other things happen you know
what happened and stuff other things
happened and it just didn't
it was irreparable at that point you
know but it was one of those ones where
like i said too little too late and it
was across a span of years because we're
so on and off obviously you know the
full story there aren't certain things i
won't say on here but it
it kind of hit me that oh [ __ ]
in the back of my mind
she is
the comparable person now you know
because it's one of those ones where
i found like you said i found
comfortability and speaking to her yeah
because i speak to her the way i speak
to you yeah and that says a lot for me
yeah yeah a lot for me yeah because i'm
i am myself when i'm with you i am
myself when i'm with bella there are
only certain people i'm myself with yeah
and i've found that and to be able to be
myself with a female that i'm also
[ __ ]
and it's reciprocated oh sign me up
by the time i was too young and naive to
even know that that's what i wanted
because i wanted to have my cake and eat
at the time and the maddest thing about
it at that time i didn't even have any
sightings
you were just i would i was just
necessarily be a man i was just
i was speaking my truth yeah and i
didn't know my truth would hurt that
much because i was naive in the
situation because i didn't understand
the severity of my words
make sense 100
so it was
it was tough for me to deal with because
i only realized how deep it was when she
said it back to me yeah like this is
actually what you said do you not
understand the implications of what
you're saying do you know what i mean in
that context and that's what like oh
[ __ ] okay and then it was up and down
that's why we were never on the same
path
um so
fast forward to future relationships
that's why i feel like now or growing up
after that i felt as if i couldn't
necessarily afford to speak my mind one
hundred percent in case
it comes back
one in case it comes back to buy me and
two the maddest thing about that is
even though i knew
my level of comfortability was nowhere
near what my level of comfortability
with said girl at the time
like future girlfriends passed this one
was nowhere near compared to
that previous one i still held back how
i spoke
so not to hurt their feelings yeah and
that was very subconscious
um but it also
became a pattern because
the more and more i did it the harder
and harder it would be for me to
actually say my mind and
i will start to think maybe she's
thinking where the [ __ ] is this coming
from yeah this is not the future that i
know yeah because this is not have you
spoken to me before not in terms of like
i will speak rudy or whatever but i
would just speak factually and i feel
like sometimes when a man speaks
factually to a woman that they're
emotionally involved with they take that
as cold as cold-hearted you're a prick
you don't love me blah blah blah and
it's like
i find it so
i find it so um
hard to
balance the two because at the end of
the day
i have to also do what's best for me i
have to also
have some form of peace of mind because
that's all a man wants in life
literally all as remember said all a man
want is peace of mind he wants money sex
and a peace of mind
those are the only four things he really
wants in life and peace of mind is up
there yeah yeah up there so
if i can't if you can't provide me the
peace of mind willingly i am more than
happy to subsidize my feelings to create
my own peace of mind so i know we don't
argue rags bro i think a lot of men are
like that in terms of like
the peace of mind is like priority one
right so if i have to
subdue how i feel yeah in any situation
and shut my mouth and just suffer with
it as opposed to speaking my mind and
potentially dealing with the
ramifications of doing so then i would
just rather just firm it yeah i'll just
firm the pain bury it deep and then i
can just chill
and then we can just like we can just
get on with this and just forever just
live in silence i hate but to
just
just to like summarize i don't want
listeners of viewers and you guys to
think that
this is where my mentality is at this is
this is something i've tried to change
over like the past course of a year yeah
yeah you know yeah and it's only up
until recently that i've been i'll say
to myself
regardless of my next step or next
situation with the next female or
whatever i am 100 gonna be myself and
it's not that case i wasn't being myself
yeah i was just trying to protect her
feelings and not ripping off band-aids
and things like that but i would als now
going forward i will also
do the best cause action for myself
still picking and choosing my words
carefully so not to come across as if
i'm cold but to explain to them i am a
very factual person i will try and save
things as black and and as white as they
possibly can be because at the end of
the day
regardless of mine in ex's situation if
you removed me from the situation and
replaced it from another bread and you
came to me for advice i would be telling
you the same thing
so you can't be mad at me for what you
don't want to hear even though you know
it's the truth yeah i find like what
i've because i'm similar to that in
terms of like i care about the
ramifications of what i'm going to say
so more time i'll just try not to open
my mouth
what i'm trying to actively do at the
minute is before i say anything
is to portray my intent
before i try and explain my feelings
because i understand that because i
realized as well i've realized recently
that feelings and language are two three
completely different things and just say
we're like i same way with like bella
for example
if she there's bare times where she's
trying to say something to me is uh
there's a word in portuguese for this
but there isn't a word in english for it
and it's like because there is no
feelings don't have words that you can
articulate specifically yeah every
single time yeah and it's like sometimes
you'll have a thought or a feeling in
your head and you're trying to get that
intent and that feeling across to that
person it's like i can't articulate it
i need to tell you that i'm when i say
this i'm trying to get you to understand
this but before i say it just know
that's where my heart is at yeah because
what i say could be misconstrued as just
cold as [ __ ] yeah but i'm just trying my
best to be as factual and as truthful as
i can possibly be in this one sentence
and then like
it doesn't always help because they just
take what you say hasn't when you say it
but i'm like i'm just trying to let you
know that like these are the thoughts i
have in my head i just can't say it i
just don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] english words are for it um
but yeah bro it's it's a tough old game
and then like when you look back into
like i feel like i've always thought i'm
too young to have past relationship
trauma
but that's not that's definitely stuff i
thought it was just childhood trauma or
nothing yeah yeah yeah
trauma and that's what i'm dealing with
but i'm definitely dealing with like
bare past relationship trauma and i've
i've realized in past relationships as
well to avoid
i've definitely sabotaged relationships
i've had in the past
to avoid and it's like a it's very
oxymoronic because
um what i've done in the past is to
avoid hurting people's feelings through
my words yeah i end up trying to get
them to not want to be the relationship
themselves yeah so they can break up
with me and i can be like cool so then i
do [ __ ] that sabotages the relationship
yeah but then the reason it's awesome
moronic is because i don't like people
don't like not liking it yeah so i don't
want to hurt your feelings so i'll just
do backstage [ __ ] that piss you off so
you can break up with me but i also
don't want you to think i'm a prick so
once you have broken up with me and you
hate me
i try and win you back yeah yeah because
i don't want you to dislike me i don't
even want to be with you i don't like me
as a human being yeah i just don't want
you to think i'm a bad guy yeah but then
i'm end up getting back with you because
i try so hard for you to like me again
that you like me again and you're like
all right well let's just pick up where
we left off and i'm like
like no yeah and then i just do the
whole thing again until the point where
i actually just emotionally completely
cut off and then i'll just send you a
text and be like i'm just not feeling it
and like that's that's been like a
running
theme throughout like pretty much all of
my relationships where as soon as i
realized like um i don't think i want to
be here anymore yeah i start doing
things
and like to sabotage actively sabotage
the relationship yeah
so that i don't have to have an awkward
conversation
it's toxic as [ __ ]
that's why like
most of my ex-girlfriends hate me
but i could have just been honest i'm
like bro you know what i'm just not
feeling this the thing is
as much as it's tough because obviously
we're never gonna know
what the honesty at that given moment
would do for the woman obviously
everyone says honesty is the best policy
and a woman would always
in the long run appreciate the honesty
now then find out x amount of time years
months later because time has been
wasted yeah but within the same breath
you don't understand how i'm feeling
right now regardless of
it's hard for me to
feel
as bad as i feel in this relationship or
in this situation
and then to unbeknownst to you rip the
band-aid off and break up with you
whilst you've pretty much not done that
much wrong yeah i'm just not feeling you
anymore yeah exactly and it's also like
you can't just say it
prematurely exactly you don't they
obviously they're like oh so obviously
it's tough because
you can't just one day be like i'm not
feeding you yeah
because they're like obviously like you
said where is this coming from why is
this happening how do we get here all
this stuff but then you don't want to
plant a seed two months prior i'm like
ah i'm maybe a little bit not happy with
this and that for her when you know
you're on a spiral downhill yeah
so i had to try different things so like
just try and reignite this this this
this this and your back your mind you're
thinking there's not really probably
anything you can do because this is a
train that's just going down here i'm
tapped out yeah yeah i'm emotionally
tapped out and it's nothing it's not
your fault it's literally not your fault
i'm just at that place where i'm just
like i just need someone else
unfortunately it's not you
unfortunately
anyway guys um yeah weird introduction
for today so welcome um as always guys
before we do anything else what we need
you to do is pause the episode right
here head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs why are you
laughing i'm just smiling
oh my god um sorry bella's in the studio
today guys behind the camera yeah um
but yeah patreon.com full-size shits and
gigs and you're gonna
pay three pound a month 10p a day run
the p to smg guys and uh get yourself a
bonus episode every single thursday
you've got three years of
old content to catch up on and then you
become part of the cult babies okay
they're a small group of intimate people
who [ __ ] suck
they're like
regularly [ __ ] suck yeah and they are
just creating breeding grounds as we do
they're chirps and in the comments
people are leaving their instagrams in
there saying that justin i've seen bare
comments like i've just turned my thing
off private
like head on over to get me yeah
yeah we're not trying to solicit
anything but what i was saying is
it turns up over on patreon it goes down
it goes down over there and the content
is juicy as always guys um we're just in
the midst of
setting up a discord chat over there so
you guys can mingle a little bit better
yeah um i have a little bit more instant
back and forth
ping pong and maybe we'll dip our toe in
there over there your cult leaves will
will peek over the hedge just to make
sure everything's okay
no one's taking a piss yeah yeah yeah
just so the ecosystem is it's blended
nicely over there got running water yeah
and then we'll run it back again behind
the veil yeah um the silk curtain one
time so guys head on over to patreon uh
that's where the good [ __ ] is if you are
watching us on youtube please for the
love of god like the video if you liked
the video chirp sitting in the comments
as always and subscribe and hit the
notification bell
um
and then on top of that guys if you are
listening on spotify apple podcast
audible amazon music itunes whatever it
is please subscribe and leave a nice
five-star preferable review but just say
how you feel tell us how you really feel
guys
and without any further ado my comrade
save a man from a leopard in chadisa let
me find out where chidiza was hold on i
think it's a city it's a city in africa
i don't know which
um
country
it's in zambia it's a town in zambia oh
okay yeah so a man introducer has fought
and killed a leopard with the help of
his dogs after they attacked his farm
that's the leopard on the floor [ __ ]
wow
like i saw that i thought
because in my head
i can see that happening yeah yeah
because that's something that will
happen in like the rural african areas
probably like south america as well yeah
i mean
i'm thinking cool but i know there's
people that are listening to this or
seeing us that have that can't even they
can't comprehend that i can't comprehend
that
a [ __ ] left leg just running up on
man and me and my two dogs need to have
him up they need to obviously i think
i'd body a leopard i definitely body a
cheetah leopard's a little bit weightier
but
yeah they're big
ah
come on man
yeah come on man a leopard yeah i'll
spin his jaw up with two dogs
yeah
to be fair the statement of their so
that says he fought off a leopard uh a
leopard with the help of his two dogs
yeah and probably it was the two dogs
fought off a leopard with the help of
some breath
he just went in there the last minute
just
yeah so joseph was in his was in the
early hours of sunday um august 14th
attacked by a leopard which had come for
his domestic animals 1.5 kilometers away
from chidiza
um he was armed with a knife and an axe
and went out to check the noises
so only to find the leopard which had
immediately charged on him [ __ ] now
that's terrifying
as the as the wild animal was fighting
with uh bandar that's his name um his
two dogs came to his rescue giving him a
chance to kill it so he was there first
he was there first up in arms bro
yeah authorities from the department of
national parks and wildlife suspect the
animal could have been
coming from the neighboring mozambique
and so not protected in the areas of the
chidiza district i could never live in
one of these areas bro see my man
this is the break i scratched him up
yeah bro
oh yeah
[Music]
a knife and an axe bro and the leopard
still had him up like that bro of course
to be of course it would bro it's this
is that's a leopard's job
not me found that's a leopard's job no
it's a leopard doing leopard [ __ ] but
like an axe and a knife
i'm pretty sure i could body i reckon i
could body a
leopard solo with axel knife
i think i don't know the thing is right
i've only held
you hold a knife every day when you cook
i've only held an axe probably two or
three times in my life let me go ahead
so i don't really know what my dexterity
is gonna be like in a fight not known
with a human with a leopard bra i reckon
i'd be clued up like i reckon i'll be in
the zone i'm not even chatting [ __ ] the
thing is i know i think i know i i'm
actually
[ __ ]
i feel like i would time the leap
perfectly
and just
clock him on his head and then just
come in
at you it's coming at you i'll be scared
don't get me wrong it'll be a fight or
flight response to be fair yeah i hope
you don't freeze
i couldn't i couldn't freeze you say
that i couldn't i physically couldn't
freeze bro you say that and you know the
maddest thing as to why
i don't know whether you might freeze
but you will never know that you will
freeze there's a show um on netflix
called um what's that pregnancy watch
um
prank encounters
um the brother that's in um
the strangest thing gatton i'm the guy
with the teeth the guy that talks about
that with a lisp
he's got a show on um netflix called
pranking cowards he does
what i say elaborate pranks hilarious oh
okay
[Music]
the premise of the show is they get two
strangers
into us into like a secluded room or
area or house or whatever and obviously
they prank them but they don't know
obviously they're going to be pranked
one comes from one direction another one
comes from another direction everyone
else is an actor and they
end up in this house and then the whole
thing starts to unfold in whatever the
prank would be but
the reason why i'm going on to that is
because
nine times out of ten if it's a boy and
a girl that being pranked the girl is on
job i swear the girl is on job mandem
are frozen james
and there was one bro there was one
where what was the what was the woman
was like actually
bro
so so one of the actors was by a wall
and a [ __ ]
a dead person grabbed him broke through
the wall grabbed him i was draped in him
the when i see them i've never seen a
man freeze like that in his life the
woman ran up to him like he looks back
at me help me
scream help me
james he was just staring i swear he
thought his life was over oh
no point she was screaming help me
when i say women's fight or flight
response shock you fair enough bro i
mean fair enough but i'm not freezing
with a with a leopard bro i'm not saying
you would but i'm just saying you just
never yeah to be fair you never know i
think the worst thing i would do
is lob the app oh yeah the things i
already know i'm going to do yeah and
i'll be able to start yeah and then as
soon as you remember the the mountain
lion video from back a day when it was
chasing that breath on the on the the
mountain trail
yes and he was doing this too yes and
just kicking up dust yes yes yes as soon
as the leopard did this thing i would
love that i just miss
and then i'm [ __ ] because all you guys
are little knights yeah a little knife
and that's when i turned my back and run
and it was catching me like that fam
there you'll feel claws in your face
that would turn me back around because
if i made it two steps and then
fantasized about the claws gripped in my
traps
i would immediately turn around
please please please please do whatever
you want to me just stop just stop don't
kill me
[ __ ]
if you want whatever you're looking for
let me pattern it for you i've got
stakes in there please [ __ ] off if i'm
claws on your back you would jump and
grip no i couldn't because then it's
going to get your face and [ __ ] like
that rips your back no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no fall on the ground
like that like a worm yeah bro yeah bro
it's it's it's nuts i couldn't yeah oh
bro i'm actually can feel the breath and
the teeth on my ear like no way
i'd have to face it like a man but yeah
i reckon i don't think i'm going to
freeze up but i think the worst possible
thing i would do is i'll get comfortable
start a jab step and then when it's
going to move to man i will just lob the
thing and it'll just bounce off the
floor
[ __ ]
but yeah that's that anyway that's a
juicy funny fun fact of the day um
cool since we're talking about shows
real quick i was going to do this later
but i'll do it now
to
show ah
it's going to say two show
recommendations
one's a kind of recommendation the other
one you can spoil that one then i can
spoil that one if if it's just a kind of
recommendation am i gonna watch it
i hope not oh there's kind of not a
recommendation but it kind of is it's a
weird one anyway sandman oh okay i'm
it's not a recommendation bro don't
spoil it i do want to watch it okay i
won't spoil it it's been number one for
time
on the series so yeah why why what they
didn't even show in the thing tick tock
told me it's actually a dc
uh dc comics like
uh what would i call it rendition okay
um
and the concept is good so the concept
is
um it follows this sound man
and they call him his name's lord
morpheus and he owns like the dream in
realm so they've got like um different
realms in the universe and there's like
different uh they call him the endless
so there's like different entities that
are that come into this family of the
endless which is the sound man who's
like controls the dreaming there's uh
desire and despair there's death and
like they're all siblings
anyway
we'll begin with d yeah yeah and then
like there's other people like there's
lucifer and like all these other people
um
and basically the premises is that he
controls the dreaming he
i won't spoil it but he's away for a
long time
um and throughout that time like there's
nightmares and uh dreams and stuff that
escape into the real world and he has to
do a job of like getting them back and
also understanding what's going on and
other interactions that he has with
people throughout the universe and all
this other [ __ ] yeah
so
it starts off it's ten episodes
i've got one to go
it's start they're all like
i think they're like 45 to an hour long
um it starts off as a recommendation
because the first few episodes bang i'll
swear the first few episodes bangs and i
was like i want balls deeper in this
[ __ ]
but then it has random episodes you can
tell it's a comic book rendition because
they really
you can it feels like i don't know
because i haven't read the comics it
feels like they give a lot of
fan service so i feel like there's
certain arcs in this comic
that are very like
fan very like well respected by the fans
of the actual comics that they give like
a whole episode to okay yeah but like to
us as general just viewers of the thing
it's so random okay it's like if it
feels like a filler episode okay because
you're like why am i watching this how's
it what the [ __ ] has this got to do with
the story there's a whole episode on
from what i can perceive is nothing yeah
um and there's only 10 episodes yeah and
like there's little bits like that and
then sometimes it gives me very much you
know when like around christmas time
there's always like a weird bbc show
that has like
mystical dragons and [ __ ] in it
and there's like it's all like it's
always like a three-part series on bbc
one or something around christmas it
gives very much those vibes sometimes
okay so sometimes it's super dark
loads of gore loads of swearing loads of
violence and you're like [ __ ] sometimes
it's very like
so it's a hit and miss yeah
okay and the longer it goes on and i've
only got one episode to go i'm a bit
like
you're just going to finish it i'm going
to finish it for the sake of finish it
but i'm not gas to finish it whereas the
first two three i was like oh
i was binging it okay i was binging it
now the real recommendation
the servant on apple tv the servant okay
okay okay so one was like ron weasley
yeah yeah yeah yeah bro okay
okay i'm only on the first season
comment how episodes i'm in yeah oh my
god you know me on apple tv
we've said it before they physically
don't miss yeah bro they physically
cannot miss bro it's a show i'm only a
few episodes in i'm like episode six
maybe seven maybe um of season one but
bro the concept alone oh so i won't
spoil it but
the concept is is that there's a family
like a very like middle class family
husband and wife
um
he works as like a chef she works as a
news anchor i think uh stroke like
journalist whatever
and um
basically
they hire a nanny to look after their
like 18 week old baby or whatever
but
um this doesn't really spoil it but this
kind of sets it up for the premise but
basically the
wife
they've got like a i can't remember the
name of the
reborn i think reborn doll
very looks so much like a real baby it's
[ __ ] creepy but their child is a doll
and they hire a nanny to look after this
doll because their 18 week old baby died
and she had a psychotic breakdown the
wife
where she physically couldn't handle it
and their therapist or whatever
suggested try this doll
and then she physically doesn't know
it's a doll
the psychosis is so deep she doesn't
know it's a dog she thinks it's her kid
okay okay so then they hire this nanny
she hires this nanny to come in as like
an au pair and live in um to look after
this doll
and
obviously the wife doesn't know mr doll
so she's like introducing the baby and
the nanny's playing
like normal playing house yeah so when
the wife's away one time the husband's
like cool
put the [ __ ] doll down but do you
mean
this because you must be scared
let's address this yeah she won't put
the doll down she's like tapping the
baby she's like no it's fine that's all
good he's like
big man
put the doll down i'll explain
everything but i'm not in on this yeah i
need him i need you to act normal for a
second yeah please
yeah the nanny's [ __ ] weird bro
treats it like a baby
treats it like a [ __ ] baby and then
the
husband feels like he's losing his mind
he's like who is this [ __ ] yeah so he's
trying to do a little bit of
reconnaissance and figure out who is
this [ __ ] and no one knows the baby's
dead apart from the husband
obviously the wife doesn't even know the
baby's dead
um so the husband the therapist and the
nanny baby the husband the therapist
her brother who's paid by the ron whizzy
guy and her dad who i haven't met yet
um
so
the the brother and the husband are very
close so
when
the the nanny's like playing house with
this baby
he bails the brother get here yeah cause
this is moving this is moving wild i
just need a stable mind at my house yeah
that balance everything else yeah
because these lot are acting wild to me
anyway push this is where the the juice
actually starts it's a bit of a spoiler
but this is where the actual show gets
started so he goes in so the
um everything's all good
she's playing house with this this
[ __ ] doll the wife's happy
the husband's losing his mind but he's
just dealing with it he fam
throw it back to the beginning of the
episode he just wants peace and quiet
yeah he's willing to play ball with this
[ __ ] doll yeah as long as it gives
him peace and his wife is happy
he doesn't give a [ __ ] if the nanny's
doing whatever he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about anything as long as happy so he's
chilling one day here's some coughing
he's like what the [ __ ] is that goes
upstairs
there's a real [ __ ] baby in the car
there's a real [ __ ] baby in the car
and
premise that i forgot to and uh to say
is the
nanny
is religious
in a weird voodoo way
she prays
she prays and you know when they like do
that like whipping [ __ ] she does all of
that and she makes little voodoo like
things and she was hanging like a weird
like
like wooden cross kind of like doll
above the cot
and the husband was like [ __ ] that took
it down yeah and um
he's been cursed ever since oh i'm not
surprised he's been cursed of course i
was thinking as soon as you touch that
oh you're in trouble
his life started to take a spiral
downhill but then after all this is
happening the baby there's a real
[ __ ] baby in that car so he confronts
her who the [ __ ] baby is that yeah she
says it's your baby bro uh the wife or
the nanny
the wife obviously doesn't know any
[ __ ] difference between there's a
baby or a doll yeah it's her you yeah
that's all she sees yeah it's her you
call's the brother-in-law get here
yesterday yeah get the [ __ ] over here i
need a stable mind bro
brother comes up starts doing dick games
yeah he hires a private investigator and
the story goes from there i would say
anything else the story goes from there
juicy
juicy like apple tv don't miss bro
don't miss they don't they [ __ ] don't
and only i've only been i started
watching this thinking this is [ __ ]
sick only to find out there's only
there's like four scenes of it out
already oh [ __ ] yes bro okay yes bro
i was just watching you thinking ah i
hope i can just keep going with yeah and
then i'll speak to someone and they were
like yeah there's like they're on like
season four
and i was like no they're not they can't
be this is the best news i've ever heard
they're on season four okay bet i
haven't i don't remember the last time i
started a show that was like three or
four seasons deep i don't remember the
last time true true truth oh i can't
wait to bang it out gang it's so good
right i'll jump
anywhere i'm pretty sure i don't
remember but obviously when apple tv
started like doing its thing i'm pretty
sure this show was like their flagship
show oh is it i'm pretty sure it was i
remember seeing it advertised everywhere
okay so yeah it's it's oh
so bro you're gonna love it gang you're
gonna love it and you'll know why
when you see his kitchen yeah and his
work ethic yeah you'll know why i like
this show okay it's just aesthetically
it's just like oh sailors here's the
dream job say less but anyway oh so good
sound man yeah okay
servant i watched seven [ __ ] sam i
watched seven first literally [ __ ]
samuel yeah literally i'm so
disappointed because there's such really
really good bits in it but other bits
i'm just like
i can't be asked for this all right
falling asleep three times this week
trying to get through it oh mad oh it's
been it's been a [ __ ] nightmare okay
what is going on guys let's take a very
very very very quick break to
pay some bills and
spread the love on our culti sponsor
man escapes okay guys so when we're in
the log cabin everyone needs those
smooth sacks okay
and the only way we're going to get
those smooth sacks is with the new man
escape product guys who asked for it and
they listened
they've just brought out the ultra
smooth package to europe guys okay
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 is the best electric shave for your
balls but if you're looking for a closer
shave
or prefer to go completely bare down
there ultra smooth package is for the is
the perfect set it's time to shave that
bush of yours and get right to the roots
right to the roots by going to
manskate.com
and for 20 off plus free shipping please
use the code sng sierra november golf
that's sng sierra november manskit.com
20 off plus free shipping and then the
ultra smooth package can be yours guys
thank you very much
let's get back to the juicy episode
today
um but you had a trash news night um i
think so yeah i just need to figure out
which one it is trash news of crash news
of this week
r kelly's former god daughter states
singer made her have sex with him from
the age of 15.
right
before you get into this actually no no
say the whole thing and then we'll talk
about it singer r kelly's former
goddaughter has come forward as another
victim of the convicted singers acts of
sexual assault with minors the now's 37
year old alleges the singer made her
have sex with him hundreds of times at
the age of 15.
the woman says that the woman says she
asked kelly to be her godfather in the
1990s when she was only 13 and state
that things quickly became sexual
that's all that's all of it only context
they give us so let me get this straight
she was 13
we don't know what relation she has to
to r kelly but she asked him will you be
my godfather and then assuming from that
he hop skip she gave an inch and he took
a mile um he took her childhood took
everything from her
he took everything from her that's not
even funny i'm not laughing i know but
it's just the way you say this i'm
trying not to laugh
i took everything
um right so i don't understand that but
okay
um
right when i saw this
i was like
first of all i i believe her of course
of course
but i was thinking
our kelly must have heard this came out
and rolled his
eyes
and thought
what more can you do
tyrese video what more do you want from
me and yes crying in the video
bro he wasn't thinking like i'm done
i'm i'm not getting out yeah yeah yeah
like you're wasting your breath you guys
have won yeah yeah the agenda has won
yeah i'm not leaving penn
lawyer yeah yeah yeah like he must have
been thinking bro kick a man while he's
down i've got cases on me and you want
to tr why just
you already left it years you heard that
i pissed on it yeah years ago years ago
you should have piped up there you
didn't say nothing now i'm behind bars
and it's clear i'm not getting out yeah
that's when you want to just sprinkle
more dirt on me just allow me just allow
me bro
um such a weird one when i saw that i
was i was thinking why now
obviously
there's a lot to i'm sure it's more
about her healing of course then
anything of course but one of the first
things that came to my head when i saw
it was like raw
i mean i'm not rooting for kelly but
[ __ ] here now
jesus christ kelly
he must be thinking oh [ __ ] oh no
another one yeah i'm not going to call
for this yeah i'm not going to call it
he might as well admit whether it's true
or not he must be like yeah yeah yeah
i'm not going to i'm not going to call
yeah
i'm not putting on a suit again for this
foolishness i'm not going to court
hundreds of times
christ yeah that's that that actually
took the smile off my face hundreds of
times it took the smile off my face
hundreds of times
bro
how did he find the time for this
because he was a hardworking guy
how did he find the time he was the hard
work he had music coming out
he had records upon records i believe i
can fly
space jam soundtracks
and he's having time to run up in high
schools just drapes him black girls
he had time to forge signatures on
aliyah's like parental yes just a wi-fi
literally
nah bro
he's a demon yeah
he's actually a demon he is he is
wow kelly's the worst
let's move on let's see he's the worst
wow i don't know where you have the time
or the energy for this it's a demon
please separate the music the artist
from the rapist
you can't are you done listening to
arcadia someone said to not well
someone said someone knows i don't think
i'll never stop listening to him or
think about him this way because for me
i won't yeah i'll swear he's like he
still
likes him
oh right yeah with me i'm like
yeah i don't relate
um
like i don't relate like remix to
ignition
to like a pedophile yeah i just vibe to
the song
because
it's so hard because i feel like
in this if
if this was probably 15 years ago
everything about arcadia was coming out
15 years ago
i feel like there'll be a vast majority
of people still [ __ ] with his music
not him his music whereas
nowadays because of how everything is so
out in the open with social media and
things like that people's opinions
people's opinions of
people think other people's opinions
matter to them so much more than it
actually does
they would say i'm never going to listen
to it again the thing is
i'm also on that stage because i i don't
think i've listened to his music yeah
i'm drawn to this music you know anyway
since but if it was but
it's it's exactly if it was at the time
and
if it's also a case of
if i'm in a place where his music has
been played for example remix to
ignition parts you can't
that's
undeniably a bop yeah do you know what i
mean
it's undeniable it's undeniable i don't
know who this person is that's singing
all i know is that my waist is moving
yeah and it's not my fault yeah and it's
not it's not i'm not trying to put money
in a pedophile's pocket but i just want
to vibe and enjoy my night i don't want
to get into the politics of it like if
if the dance is coming to an end and
bump and grind comes on oh
it's nobody's fault yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's nobody's fault but the dj
yes
do you know what i mean that's nobody's
fault but the dj's bro bump and grind
that's a song i can't help but wind your
waist bro i was listening to um because
it's only when i watched the the
documentary yeah the documentary was
dark it was so dark women were on that
documentary james yeah yeah so women
upon women upon women crazy they said
that he used to literally just rock up
into a random high school teachers
didn't say nothing bro
straight into the demonstrate to the
telly yeah bro um but there was um
i didn't realize because obviously i
never knew he had such an influence on
like aaliyah's career like he was elia's
career yeah yeah
i was listening the other day and it's
from aj number number yes and then the
album cover he's in the background it's
him
it's her and kelly brown i didn't know
that i couldn't believe it was bold yeah
i didn't know that my whole life would
have yeah to be fair i i think i only
knew once i watched the documentary yeah
only once i watched the documentary and
saw that i was like oh right i did a
part of my car the other day and i was
like oh ra yeah he's actually there he's
in there bro wild but yeah bump and
grind if brown mcgregor comes home i'm
holding a wine on someone someone or
something and then they turn to me and
say oh do you support our kelly i'm like
what are you on about this is music yeah
well i'm just trying to wind them dick
yeah
i wouldn't even i i wouldn't even
understand why they're asking me that
you know what i mean that's how
disconnected i am from this vibe and
this wine
to this person this monster yeah
i don't know i said this white if you're
there if i'm if i'm holding this waist
and i'm
if i'm holding this waist
here and then like you know when you
squeeze the top of the cheek yeah if i'm
holding this wine here and then we're
going out if a bumper goes she turns
around this yeah
if it's that grippy and the hip flex off
yeah
you're not going anywhere yeah and she
turns around and says are you a
supporter of our kelly
turned around
i'm like
where did that come from and she would
have to break she would have to break it
down for me the song and i'm like oh ra
no
and then i would expect it to turn into
listen are you in support of r kelly
bro that's that that's how disconnected
i am i don't know
[ __ ] but yeah it's it's true also though
because his music isn't relevant anymore
so very easy just just not play r kelly
yeah but if drake was just out here
pissing on children
that's where it gets sticky no pun
intended no pun intended
this is how sticky it get because bro
drake's got bangers
i don't know
if the world will be able to handle that
no they really couldn't i i'm not joking
i think at a very superior government
level someone will have to turn the
blind eye yeah they're not burying you
yeah because
that can't run he feeds so many people
and like
his pockets run way too deep like
the taxi pays for canada alone
someone has to shut up someone has to
shut this [ __ ] down yeah from it was it
was
when homegirl from stranger things was
running a yap a few years ago do you
remember i think so many people and
drake are so close yeah yeah yes yes yes
and something like yes oh i text him
saying oh i love you and he takes me
back oh i love you too and everyone was
like
and no one was thinking drake you
bastard everyone's thinking [ __ ] shut
up [ __ ] the music what are you trying to
do to him think of the music
no one was thinking sweat swimming like
that they're thinking if this child
doesn't shut up
what is she doing like someone where's
her pr yeah yeah yeah she's doing this
to all of you yeah she's spinning lies
clearly
and i don't like what she's saying bro
yeah drake's got too many bangers too
many bangers bro albums
the world wouldn't handle it yeah i
wouldn't be able to handle that yeah
we'd have to have like vigils and
funerals and stuff we wouldn't know what
to do because what music are we
listening to now yeah he's everywhere he
he's everywhere music he is
bro we'd have to flip culture on his
head yeah
ah
mad mad yeah bro that's true he's yeah
yeah that
that physically can't right you cannot
you can't but anyway
we've got trying to laugh no we do have
childhood i need to drink a lot of water
and relax my face muscles hang on just
give me like a minute anyway um try not
to laugh as per usual it's going to be
dark humor edition
bless
okay
here we go right eye contact yeah
of course
i fell miserably at the last one bro i
felt miserably that was everything so
clean
you laughed at almost every single one
right
hold on
all right i'm ready what did the titanic
say as it sank
i'm nominating all the passengers for
the ice bucket challenge
cool
if someone burns to death
do they get a discount at the
crematorium
cool cool i got this
what is the worst combination of illness
alzheimer's and diarrhea you're running
but can't remember where
okay good you're doing well yeah i
actually am i'm i'm in the zone today
we'll see about that
what makes sad people jump
i know this one's gonna [ __ ] me up
say it again sorry sorry what makes sad
people jump
what
bridges
you're an idiot
all right cool
wow
wow
wow wow wow okay
my girlfriend dumped me so i stole her
wheelchair
guess who came crawling back
[Laughter]
wow
all right say list you got me on that
one
my favorite disney movie is the
hunchback of notre dame i love a hero
with a twisted backstory
all right cool cool you're doing well
you're doing really well
i like oh sorry i work with animals the
guy says um the guy says to his tinder
date
that's so sweet she replies
i like a man who works with animals
where do you work
i'm a butcher he says
cool cool
i will never forget my dad's last words
you raised my search history son
cool yeah yeah cool this is all right
man this is all right it's all right i
made a website for orphans
it doesn't have a home page
cool
last one last one yeah yeah
what is the difference between iron man
and iron woman
one is a superhero
and the other is a simple command
[Laughter]
wow
wow okay cool you held it i heard it for
most of those yeah that was cool that
was all right well played um i'm gonna
try and come back next week cool with
some yeah i'll i'll i'll make a note
that uh
next time is uh oh wait no you've got
for next week already over next week
already all right bet
cool all right maybe the week after
um
right i've got a
fan request right so final request for
today
the uh title of the question is is
how to make my husband a freak
so
i'm 34 female married to 28 male
okay yeah okay indeed
before i met my husband i was slaying
dick
i was in these streets and loving it
um
i was targeting younger men
until my younger teen i was targeting
younger men and by younger i mean over
21
but only for sex and not to date
i'm not trying to be in no grooming
situation it was always a nice little
bang and then we went our separate ways
i went younger because these older men
were tired and i was just over it bro i
stay tired
i stay
tired she knows she had to go for that
21 year old she said i was looking for
that crazy energetic scent i knew that
bunny said you won't get her from me boy
you won't get that from me
um
so
my now husband was supposed to be the
same thing but he ended up [ __ ] me
for three days straight
it was that freak nasty marathon sex
um it was like this for a while
just getting up to piss
pound a gatorade and a snack on a
protein bar and we was back at it [ __ ] i
would be three days of this
my tour would be in agony sore and so
uninteresting yeah
bro i don't want even i don't want to
think about it yeah same
same
he was on that cialis or science he was
having herbs
he was he was doing infinity stones yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um right so now i wasn't looking for a
ray ship but apparently my husband was
addicted to the puss
and pursued me for months i was not
having it i was on my whole [ __ ] but he
wore me down now we're married
here's my problem
when i first met him i told him the
freaky and sometimes depraved [ __ ] i was
into and he was about without it
they always are fam of course but now
two years later and the sex is still
good but not as frequent and not as
freaky
um i get that it can't be all freaky all
the time but sometimes i feel like i was
bamboozled
bamboozled
pause
sneeze
sorry
so sometimes i feel like i was
bamboozled tricked into believing this
man was about that life and apparently
he isn't
so how do i bring the freak back out of
my husband
do i smack the [ __ ] out of him and tell
him to get into the bedroom and let me
suck the skin off his tool
um
now i know that my uh now i know that
might work but how do i get him to kick
me in the back and tell me to bend over
so he can break me like he used to
i'm always the one who's doing the
seducing and initiating and i just want
him to grab me by the throat and tell me
what he wants
am i asking for too much
i'm not sure if this even matters but
he's a nerdy white guy and i'm a
confident black woman
i don't think it should matter but i
grew up very different and sometimes
wondering if that should be considered
his life was reminiscent to the perfect
white families on tv i don't think
that's not relevant at all but within
the same breath i wasn't picturing an
interracial couple before you said that
uh no i wasn't i wasn't um at all
actually um
give me give me a run down again so
synopsis yeah um
she's 34 yeah she's 28. um she was about
to she was on this street life um
banging younger guys because she just
wanted to be piped unconscious
she met him and he gave her the dick of
her life for 72 hours
i'mma [ __ ] the world for 72.
kendrick so yeah he [ __ ] the world for
72 hours um
and she was like
raw um
and then
from there she tried to lock him off and
he was like nah nah nah nah nah romney
did tom rummy didn't turn wrong with the
turn so he was banging her bang and her
banging the bang and the banging her
until the point she was like
wife me then yeah just wife me like i
just i'm here for it now just wife me so
they've been married for two years and
now two years in
they have sex but it's nowhere near
the level that he was frequent and
freaky as it was before so she's
contemplating do i just put paws on him
start smacking him about and tend to get
his arse in the bed or
but that she's saying even if i do do
that that's not what i'm looking for
yeah i wanted to kick me in the back and
say bend the [ __ ] over
i wanted to grab me by the throat and
tell me what to do and tell me what he
wants the thing because i was gonna say
originally maybe he's just not used to
being so dominant but obviously you said
they banged for three days straight and
obviously he he was piping he was piping
the life out of her so there's a part of
him that's clearly like that
um what should she do [ __ ]
um
i mean the only one of the only options
i would suggest is
she has to speak her mind and
maybe initiate in a way that
walk into the room wearing something
sexy
right inside [ __ ] sexy and that that
would make him
even though she's initiated by wearing
the actual garments but maybe that would
spur something in him to be like
i need to get back to what i used to
because my wife is clearly still wanting
to have sex at 4pm right now do you know
what i mean
like there's no
it's tough when
it's tough when you you try and compare
what you were to what you currently are
and
yeah in terms of a sex in in reference
to sex rather um because
it's it's not necessarily always going
to deteriorate but you're always going
to have peaks and troughs
in any way i [ __ ] know yeah
yeah there's a frog in there boy
in any relationship sorry about that
guys yeah so in any relationship there's
going to be peaks and troughs sexually
and regardless of whether
the woman's
um libido is going down on a man's
libido is going down it's one of those
ones where you have to speak about it
you just have to if you're in a
committed relationship or you're married
about you have to speak about it yeah as
awkward as it's gonna be or you may
think it's gonna be the outcome maybe
everything you've been looking for it's
just about the initial conversation yeah
i think as well like the more i'm
learning and hearing these stories and
stuff since we've been doing this show
the more and more i've heard like i do
also feel like
men and women
like i feel like sometimes for a guy
um i might be speaking out a term i feel
like sometimes for a guy like
we love the freak and the nastiness and
we want to do it but it's like
it's like being at a theme park it's
like living if you had to live at a
theme park you have to live in like
thorpe park yeah like i don't want to do
stealth all the time i wanted to try it
yeah and i wanted to do it i don't want
to do it up i was gassed but i live here
and i don't want to do stealth every day
let's just go to the arcade like i still
want to bang but like
the thought of having to like it's just
like how do i explain it it's stressful
to think about it's like if you're
how do i explain it like people who are
into running marathons or doing iron man
or all this stuff they love it while
they're doing it and they're passionate
about it and they would identify with it
but you can't ask them to do that every
day they want to do it like once a year
yeah and it's like and they're doing
that once a year and with the rest of
the year they're doing like five miles
here little ten miles here
they're training a bit of swimming yeah
they're still enjoying it but it's like
this is what my every day is like but
then once a year once every two years
your boy's gonna go crazy whereas like i
feel like women see something and
they're like this is the sex i want
and they're looking for someone to
provide it and then when the guy
provides it i always hear the same story
two years in three years in four years
he's just not doing it anymore yeah they
want that jail dick yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's like even the guy who comes out
of jail and gives you the jail dick he's
not gonna give you forever yeah after a
month he's done yeah after a month of
jail dick he's on to the next jailbird
yeah yeah because yeah
like guys just want
peace and quiet yeah and they want the
thrills and the fun and all that stuff
but most of the time i just want to
chill and not mmm it doesn't have to be
such a explainer experience like imagine
you could only watch films at the cinema
i'm not watching films that often bro
facts i love films but i'm not going to
the cinema every day yeah yeah i want to
watch films all the time
i want to binge was i want to watch this
i want to do that but i don't want to go
cinema and get dressed and buy popcorn
and all these things every single time i
want to go see like watch a film
you have to speak about it because there
has to be a middle ground yeah yeah yeah
there has to be a middle ground mape
and she never said they've stopped
having sex they just she said we still
have sex
and it's still good it's just not as
frequent and it's not as freaky yeah
it's freaky and
this is where you have to speak and come
to some form of agreement or some form
of middle ground where like i'm just
expressing how i feel i'm not saying
that
oh because we've had this conversation i
want freaky sex every other day for the
rest of our lives i'm just letting you
know where i'm at physically sexually
and mentally
where do we go from here yeah like i'm
putting on the table because this is me
and you there's no one else that i'm
going to give this to you i would see it
she he sounds like she needs he needs a
little reminder of just like just to let
you know
when you met me and you [ __ ] me for
three days straight that's what got you
to the table yeah
boom there's nothing else to say no i've
said do with that as you will yeah yeah
yeah the only reason you ever got in
this house was that yeah
boom dinner's on the table yeah on the
table do with that information whatever
you want to do of it and just that's the
information i feel you need to hear yeah
because
comfortable yeah a bit comfortable yeah
and that's fine i'm trying to get my
throat clogged yeah yeah you're not
providing i want to be unconscious a lot
a lot of times and i am too conscious
right now yeah yeah frustrating yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got here with like
false pretenses yeah that's what it
feels like
so just throw me a bone literally
literally block my windpipe because
that's all i've been begging for for the
past four days yeah yeah
so communication
yeah talk it out man yeah anyway guys
also are very prideful they don't want
to hear that they don't they don't want
to hear your dick is just lacking in it
no guy would ever want to hear that
would ever want to hear that yeah so
here's what it is
um
anyway unless you've got anything
further we've gotta add your questions
no straight to ig questions yeah
um so this week guys the question of the
day was or is
um
what's the dumbest thing your partner
has said
and i didn't have as many as i usually
have so i'm just gonna reel them off all
right i didn't give you the std my ex
gave it to you i just slept with her
that's funny i thought it was going to
be god can you turn the lights off i'm
cold
wow okay baby if you look to the left
you look a lot prettier
do goats lay eggs
[ __ ] off for real though where's the
clip
fam bare people ask that
he said he was flirting with a fat girl
because it's
sorry he said he was flirting with a fat
girl because it's his job as a pt to
build up her confidence he was a police
officer at the time i hadn't pt in years
i'm just
flicking it on and off as a when as and
when manchester united
girl
man
imagine
man was actually just chirping things
and said she's just a fat girl and i'm
trying to build her confidence up he
threw it under the bus under the bus
she might be my wife but you're my soul
mate
that's on trend with a lot of ones that
we get in it
he told me his name and he asked him his
surname and he repeated his name with
sir at the beginning
[Laughter]
okay cool
i told him
i told him a girl approached me saying
he was invited round for sex he said
you're overthinking
those jokes let me drive closer to the
moon for a better photo
wow
i slept with a prostitute because i
liked the chase
oh [ __ ]
stupid i didn't mean to tell her i was
single i just typed it and sent it
[Music]
uh i retract my statement that's jokes
he said awesome i just typed it and sent
it i didn't mean it i didn't mean it i
just typed my fingers were just doing
stuff and i just pressed send see single
and send
oh that's funny oh that's actually
hilarious go on i asked her how she
slept and she said like a glove
what exactly
exactly like
how does it fit like
she [ __ ] up
she [ __ ] up oh that's funny
i gave the strip of my number because
she needed financial advice
oh bro strippers have man swindled
swindled there's a couple man we know
that just
ra really can't disassociate they really
can't disassociate
oh it's funny
i love you cause you're a [ __ ] and
you've got the experience that i need
oh dear
she forced me to have sex with her it
was soft the whole time
bro there's um oh pause there's a film i
can't remember
the name of this film maybe someone will
know what it is there is a film
where
ah to be fair it might actually be the
original punisher i'm not sure
it might not be but um
the guy who plays the punisher in the
movie not the series the movie i know i
know his face by doing his name yeah the
white kind of blondish dusty blonde guy
there's a film it might be the punisher
it might be something else i feel like
it's something else there's a film where
he
gets like
moved up in his yard and he loves his
wife i think i've told you before and
there's a yat that breaks into his yard
knocks him out ties him to a chair arse
naked and rapes him
rapes him
but he
he loves it so he can't be soft he's
hard as a rock yeah and he nuts in there
yeah and he he begs himself not to nut
because he can't live with the portrait
yeah yeah yeah yeah sat on it
she sits on it and he is there like
sweating like yeah no yeah and he's so
upset when he laughs yeah he's so upset
i remember watching that phone thinking
[ __ ] i was young when i was like oh
sexy that's the best thing god that
could never be me please be me
oh god
anyway back to it what's the dumbest
thing your partner has said
women's feet are smaller so they can be
closer to the sink
wow
wow that made you blink
bro
[Music]
jesus christ [ __ ] hell indeed bro
if i [ __ ] someone else you'll be the
first to know
oh that's jokes he thought the equator
on the map was ecuador
[ __ ] what this line
he thought was the country of ethical
daughter
when i asked him why he cheated he said
why not oh that's not dumb that's ballsy
that is ballsy that's ballsy he told me
he loved me by text it was forwarded
nah
it's not a hickey i slept on my hand
that doesn't even make sense where the
[ __ ] was it bro
oh oh here yes it was like just i just
sucked that neck yeah
he lied that he had a mixed race baby
because he wanted me to believe that he
could pull white girls
what he said
i've got a mixed race you so she said
you can only get black women and he said
i can get a white [ __ ] if i want one
i've got a break yeah she was like no
you can't he said well i had to explain
my mixed race you then she said what
yeah i've got a son he's brown as [ __ ]
say something literally say something
bro lie through his scenes if i know you
don't
wow
he asked to hold my [ __ ] whilst i peed
that's
he called me sweaty instead of sweetie i
don't date men that can't spell anymore
rawr
like you typed it in yeah yeah
i don't sweaty
high sweat i was double down
do you mean sweetie no no
no i'm saying you visibly sweat every
time i see you you perspirate a lot
hello sweaty stinky [ __ ]
there's no way i'm coming clean
i did it to escape from reality but it
was nothing against you
wow
last one caught him cheating and he said
i've made the mistake of shutting out my
options before
[Laughter]
i caught him cheating and he said i've
made the mistake of shouting out my
options before
no way bro ballsy
i couldn't put all my eggs in this
basket your basket i've done that before
and i just regret it i regretted it and
all my other
[Music]
some men are just willing to just like
say
throwback to the beginning
just speak their truth yeah speak their
[ __ ] truth because like
some of that stuff is so painfully
specific yeah it has to be true oh facts
and you're like how
how
how would we how do you finesse me into
being your life partner yeah when this
is where your head's at how have we got
here yeah literally i've made the
mistake of shutting down my options
before i'm [ __ ] you worn yeah i'm not
gonna do it again i'm [ __ ] you all
there's nothing you can say or do to
change that
i need hoes
i live either that's crazy but yeah um
anyway guys that's it for this week that
is it for this week thank you so much as
always um it's another long episode i
think that was that wasn't uh medium
right medium range i think that one um
but as always guys head on over to
patreon.com to check in on us every
thursday get involved with the the cult
culture over there been till the old
episodes do whatever you want to do to
be fair even yeah i don't care what you
do over there just get there
um and as always guys love love
[Music]
you